new york city trenton north carolina
igra coke island mississippi and
northern florida that's where you get
this sort of blanche dubois scarlet
o'hara kind of classical southern accent
hi my name is eric singer i'm a dialect
coach today we're going to take a little
tour of some of the different accents of
english-speaking north america
[Music]
now a couple of quick disclaimers these
are by no means all the accents in north
america or even all the english-speaking
ones and not everyone from the same
place sounds the same accents vary by
socio-economic background generation
ethnicity and race and all kinds of
individual factors because in a very
real way
accent is
identity different people from the same
place have more or less localizable
accents and that usually has to do with
identity too now on some of our stops
we're going to be looking at some of the
most distinctive and interesting local
features but it doesn't mean that
everyone from there has that accent or
has it to the same degree i'm also going
to have some linguists and language
experts from around the continent join
me today to lend their expertise in some
of these areas hi i'm megan figueroa hi
i'm nicole peace i'm sun michaud hi i'm
kalina hi i'm amani doran one of the
things you'll notice along the way is
that accents often don't follow
political boundaries especially ones
like state lines they'll follow major
geographical boundaries things like
mountains for sure but what regional
accent differences mostly reflect is
settlement patterns and contact
historically isolated communities like
ocracoke island in the outer banks of
north carolina or the sea islands in the
low country in georgia can have really
distinctive speech ways they've had the
time and isolation necessary to diverge
and develop them that's the other thing
that makes for accent variety
time there's a lot more accent diversity
in the british isles for example where
there are local populations that have
been speaking english in their
particular way for hundreds and hundreds
of years and there's more accent
diversity on the east coast of the us
than there is west of the mississippi
it's been settled by english speakers
longer the first places english was
spoken in north america were roanoke
jamestown and of course plymouth
massachusetts where the pilgrims landed
in 1620. so let's start there the
pilgrims spoke with what we call rhodic
accents meaning they said all their r's
in fact so did almost all english
speakers in 1620 including the ones in
england that's right a southern english
accent might have used to sound
something like this it was only in the
late 18th century that fashionable young
people in and around london started
dropping their r's and from there the
trend spread to america now north of
plymouth rock we have avedyat one of the
places you might hear a boston accent
today stereotypical boston accents of
course are non-rhodic meaning no r
sounds in park your car and harvard yard
let's all get in the car and head south
down the coast now into rhode island
traditional rhode island accents here
are still non-rhodic but there's a key
vowel difference the placement for that
bowel sound in park your car in harvard
yard we call this the start valve in
boston it's usually pretty fronted park
your car in harvard yard in rhode island
it's back park your car in harvard yard
rhode island accents were shaped by a
lot of irish and italian immigration
just like new york city so many accents
they don't vary by borough by the way
that's a myth i know you guys are going
to tell me to forget about it but i'm
sorry sociolinguists have studied this
really carefully and there just really
isn't any such thing as a specifically
brooklyn or specifically bronx accent
there certainly are a lot of different
new york city accents but they vary by
socioeconomic background and by
ethnicity and other aspects of group
belonging and identity more than by
neighborhood or by borough they're
historically non-rhodic though that's
changing some in the youngest
generations for sure here's something
fun most of them have in common
the tongue tip hits the teeth or close
to them on td and n sounds instead of
you know a little further back so you
can hear that in like this kind of new
york city accent tongue tip on the teeth
times square new york city and this kind
of new york accent 22nd street times
square uh dumbo taxis traffic and so on
okay so you may have noticed that all of
these accents i've talked about so far
sound pretty
white i'm going to take a pause here and
linguist nicole holiday is going to go a
little deeper on african-american
english varieties my colleague amani
dorn is going to demonstrate some of
those accents
hi i'm nicole holliday and i'm a
linguist as we know new york has all
kinds of people in it african american
english has a lot of shared features
across regions because of its history so
black people in africa were kidnapped
and brought to what is now the united
states
at the time they didn't all speak the
same languages they spoke multiple
different african languages and those
languages came into contact not only
with each other but those languages were
also coming into contact with the
english spoken by the colonizers this
created a situation where there was a
really unusual
learning exposure to english right so
there are all these languages in contact
with each other um and for economic and
survival reasons the enslaved people had
to in some ways acquire english but the
english that they were acquiring was not
like what you learned in the classroom
right it was under this really unusual
situation of acquisition
so some of the features that we see in
modern african american english are
a result of this contact between the
african languages as well as the english
spoken by colonizers and those features
have persisted over generations after
slavery was legally ended the majority
of african americans remained in the
south but experienced really extreme
segregation this led to different
varieties of english being spoken in
black and white communities within the
south and even as they moved north
during the great migration nicole how
did the great migration influence
accents the english that we see today
spoken by african americans has some
features that have persisted throughout
generations th stopping so that might be
using something like a d sound for where
you see a written th so dat for that you
can hear that in this clip they said i
could participate online they said i
could they said i could they said i
could participate online l vocalization
so that's an l turning into a vowel in a
word like pool or pull might sound
something like pool or pull you said ask
cool cool cool cool that's cool we also
see consonant cluster simplification if
you have a series of consonants at the
end of a word you might see them turned
into just one consonant so in a word
like west you might hear it pronounced
does wes it's been a minute but she just
left she just left she just left and
anything specific to new york one
feature common in new york city is what
we call a raised vowel in words like
thought and cloth it sounds something
like oh coffee without froth on top
isn't coffee at all so let's get it
together okay let's go back to eric
thank you nicole and even that's just
the tip of the iceberg for linguistic
diversity in this incredibly diverse
city around 50 of new yorkers speak
languages other than english at home and
for half of those that language is
spanish megan figueroa is here to tell
us a little bit about one of those
varieties a variety linguists call new
york latino english new york latino
english is heavily influenced by puerto
rican spanish and dominican spanish one
remarkable feature of this variety is a
light l the sound that you would find in
a word like like
love
leaf
right so new york latino english
speakers have a particularly light l you
can hear that in this native speaker
clip i guess growing up i know what it's
like to not have a lot i know what it's
like to not have a lie lie lie in
contrast the light l when you produce
the dark l the back of your tongue
bunches so think about the words milk
and pull the lighter l was a feature of
new york latino english but latinx
people are a very diverse group of
people and they speak a variety of
varieties we'll get to more of those
later thank you megan and this single
feature is a good contrast with other
new york accents by the way because most
other new york accents are pretty dark
elves lots of lemon lollipops la la i
like to lick them
so now as we leave new york and head
south in new jersey and towards
philadelphia we cross a major dialect
boundary the online now north of this
line most people say ahn rhymes with don
south of it they say on rhymes with dawn
of course this doesn't apply at all if
you rhyme don and dawn only if you have
two distinct pronunciations that's
called the cot cot merger but we'll talk
more about that later there are a few
major dialect areas in the u.s and one
of the biggest dividing lines is between
northern dialects and midland dialects
the online basically runs right along
this boundary so as we cross over it
somewhere around trenton we've crossed
from the north to the midlands dialect
wise now another thing that starts to
happen as we get down towards philly is
that the goat diphthong starts to move
forwards in the mouth so we get go
hoagies you want to go get some hoagies
go gets maybe even a little further
forward as we get down to baltimore
especially you know
you want to get any ocean on wednesday
let's make a quick stop in dc where
nicole has some really interesting stuff
on the prosidy of local african american
speakers in my research i study prosody
which has to do with the tone and
intonation of the phrase itself in a
study i found that african american
speakers may be more likely to ask a yes
no question with a level tone or a
falling tone for white speakers we
expect a rising tone in questions like
these so something like did you do the
dishes but african-american speakers may
be more likely to say something like did
you do the dishes another feature that
we see in dc similar to new york is the
raised thought cloth vowel that ah this
is a new feature in dc and we think it's
part of a pattern of dc varieties
becoming more like northern cities as
opposed to the south you can hear that
in this clip change is needed but um
at what cost edward cost cost okay let's
go back to eric now we take a quick
detour over to pittsburgh yids are the
only people in all of north america that
smooths the math fifth on except for
maybe chicago sometimes now smoothing is
when you take a diphthong like ow
and smooth it out so it's just one sound
ah just like we have price smoothing
into much of the sound so that i
smooths out to just ah price same thing
here except with the math vowel
smoothing out to a long ass sound
you want to meet dan tan go shopping for
catches
heading back over to the delmarva
peninsula as we head down into virginia
we get something different happening
with that same mouth diphthong here it's
going to sound like oh mouth
so it's not smoothing out here it's
raisin the tongue starts a little higher
up uh instead of i so it's like oh
oh a boat host this feature is called
tidewater raisin
something similar happens with this bio
in canada and there we call it canadian
raisin but it's essentially the same
thing happening time to get out of the
house keep heading south down in north
carolina we really start to hear pretty
significant goat fronting again so the
vowel sound in boat most hope starts
with the tongue further forwards in the
mouth oh interestingly goat fronting
which is now widespread in a lot of the
american south
seems to have originated in north
carolina sometime in the last part of
the 19th century remember that regional
dialect boundaries don't necessarily
follow political boundaries they follow
settlement patterns and contact patterns
between populations so the inline part
of north carolina which is in the
appalachian highlands the original
european settlers were scotch-irish
folks and germans moving southwest from
pennsylvania due to being relatively
inaccessible and isolated for a long
time that's handy is distinct from the
lowlands and from the coastal areas
isolated speech communities are
fascinating because we can get some
really interesting sound patterns up
here you get some really dramatic face
lowering for example
so the diphthong in face starts real low
down around i
i
face
light
die
you'll also get some particular dialect
features so words and word order and
grammar things that stretch way back to
those original settlers from scotland
and northern ireland things like a
hunting and efficient and
extra sounds too like the r sound and
warsh and the h sound and hit get on
with hit here's nicole again to talk a
little bit about african american speech
in southern appalachia hi again so
african americans in appalachia are
understudied mostly because stereotypes
of appalachia are very very white
african americans in appalachia may be
more likely to be rhodic so in words
like floor
why up there on the fourth floor fourth
floor floor floor you'll get the r
whereas in other places you might get
full african americans in appalachia
also tend to follow the more general
southern pattern with respect to eye
monopolization ah in wide turning to ah
so you get wide and now the map tour
continues with eric thank you nicole
we're picking up again in north carolina
over in the outer banks there's an even
more historically isolated community
because of a shift in shipping patterns
in the mid 19th century and probably
also because of sympathizing with the
northern cause in the civil war
agriculture island was relatively
isolated from the mainland for a long
time it developed maybe one of the most
distinctive and different dialects in
north america obliging islanders will
sometimes say to tourists well it's high
tide on the sound side last night the
waterfall night the moon shine no fish
extra coke islanders are sometimes
called high tiders because of that
particularly distinctive oi sound and
their accent is sometimes taken to be
british or australian even by brits
truth be told there are some
similarities with some regional english
accents including that high toy vowel
sound which is similar to both
southwestern english accents like devon
or gloucestershire and east england
accents like norfolk and suffolk those
east and most counties of england
curiously another distinctive thing
about the old ocracoke accent is it's
also got a real sort of balance to it
which is something that both those
southwestern and those east anglian
accents also have in common north
carolina is actually one of the most
linguistically diverse states in the
country i want to bring in colleen
newmark now to talk about native
american english hello my name is kalina
newmark and i am talita denny first
nations from the northwest territories
canada i come from a strong line of dene
and metis leaders who are passionate
about our language and cultural
teachings the lumbee tribe is the
largest state recognized native american
tribe in north carolina lumbee speakers
combine and pronounce english words that
distinguish them from african-american
and southern speakers since encountering
white settlers in the mid-1800s the
lumbee have carved out a dialect of
english that is uniquely theirs one
interesting feature is that lumbee
english speakers share vowel sounds
present in the outer banks accent where
tide is pronounced toyed you can hear
that in this native speaker clip well
when he got halfway that little on
this side
on this sewing on this side
thank you kalina so that ocracoke island
high tider accent is an accent that's
disappearing fast younger ocracokers
tend to speak much more mainstream
american english there's a popular idea
that we're losing regional accents that
people are sounding more and more
similar that's true of some people in
some places especially some of these
isolated communities but it's not true
across the board there are actually
plenty of accent differences that are
getting more and more distinct over time
but of course it's a complex picture
there are parts of the south that don't
have all that much southern about them
accent wise raleigh north carolina and
austin texas are two good examples a lot
of people from those two cities may be
pretty hard to identify by their accents
which brings us to what is sometimes
called
general american what's general american
the first thing is it's not one accent
it's basically a terrible term for a
wide variety of accents that essentially
don't have a lot of obvious regionally
distinctive features in them we're going
to talk to sun michaud now sun is a
native speaker of gala a fascinating and
really important creole language spoken
in the low countries in the carolinas
georgia and florida gulla is a language
spoken in the region of the united
states called the galakichi cultural
heritage corridor which extends
officially from wilmington north
carolina down to jacksonville florida
gullah's an atlantic creole most similar
with bohemian creole english and beijing
creole in fact when i visited the
bahamas a bunch of local imitate and
i've been a local too there are a
variety of factors that inform the
language for instance the secluded
plantations on the sea island a mixture
of african languages as well as the
accents of lower class english and irish
indentured servants and slavers european
slavers were so ill-suited for the sea
islands environment that they would
often afford long periods of solitary
time to our ancestors with little to no
oversight slavers would mismatch the
languages in order to confound them and
hinder their ability to organize
rebellions now the scheme of this tactic
was designed for our gulagichi ancestors
to be forced to speak english so that
their overseers could be privy to their
communications but what slavers didn't
predict is that this first generation
english-based african pigeon would
develop into a creole a fully mature
rule-governed language of its own much
of which remains with us today due to
generations of force segregation and
eventual separation by choice before the
building of bridges that increased easy
access to and fro i'm going to walk you
through a few distinct features of the
gulligichi accent for example the kit
foot vials are reversed for the words
fish and foot to sound like fish and fit
the lot trap vowels are reversed for god
and pat to sound like gad and pot the
softening of the teas where butter and
bent would sound like butter and bean
gula speakers also drop consonants for
vowels where the two words meet for
instance in the sentences
the word for their d adds or subtracts
the d depending on if there's a
consonant or a vowel preceding it the
importance of accent to the gulligici
language simply cannot be overstated it
is the clearest bond between ourselves
and other displaced africans throughout
colonized spaces and the black diaspora
how we sound is as important as what we
say because our accent is a statement in
itself this has been your goal to teach
your son micho
stay safe and as always we out you
peace thank you so much son so if you're
keeping count that's six southern
accents already even though we're not
being remotely comprehensive here and
we've only been through a few states
lots more to come as we get into the
piney woods bell southern georgia
alabama and mississippi and northern
florida we get into one of the parts of
the south that's always been rhodic a
lot of the south was historically
non-rhodic that's where you get this
sort of blanche dubois scala o'hara kind
of classical southern accent you can
hear that in this clip here i've always
depended on the kindness
of strangers you hear how there's no r
in strangers strange strange strange
that's a non-rhodic accent but that's
changed and changed fast over the last
few decades so most younger white
southerners are now rhodic
most of piney woods belt though they
always have been now nicole talked about
the fact that some african-american
speakers in southern appalachian smooth
out the i
diphthong the price vowel in some words
and we get a long i sound but in other
words it stays a diphthong i
and this is a pattern we find in a lot
of the south and most of the piney woods
belt though there's always been what we
can describe as full price smoothing
where some southerners smooth the
diphthong in words like fly rise and
ride but use diphthong in rice and right
here in the piney woods belt we're going
to smooth them all fly rise rod and rise
right life night and so on there's an
interesting posture thing here too
which is that you start to get tongue
tips that are very edge focused and what
i mean by that is that instead of using
this part of the tongue
the blade for things like t and d sounds
uh so that there's a lot of surface
contact
duh
we just use the narrow edge of the
tongue so it's a more focused contact
area
ten tired turtles talk about dentists
we're gonna end part one right here but
we're gonna continue this all the way
across the continent we're gonna go to
chicago and southern california and yes
absolutely we'll get out in a boat up in
canada see you next time for part two